une discussion avec l'or et c'est devenu
s'excuser après c'était adorable elle
est venue elle m'a expliqué on est
repartir sur une bonne base et puis
voilà c'était fini pour elle aussi
c'était très compliqué parce qu'elle a
eu il y a plein de gens qui lui sont
tombés dessus sur les réseaux tout ça
aussi
je sais qu'elle était elle était sale ça
lui a fait mal en fait tout ça mais toi
aujourd'hui voilà c'est vrai que si vous
étiez si vous étiez pas compris en fait
on n'était pas sur la même longueur
d'onde mais plus même elle a fait elle a
fait son travail de prof quoi voilà elle
était autoritaire elle allait jusqu'au
bout quoi mais voilà je lui en veux pas
c'est pas grave tu regrette tout ce qui
s'est passé autour ou pas du tout
c'est-à-dire tout là toute la voilà
j'aime pas dire polémique mais le buzz
voilà qui est ouvert
c'est un peu embêtant quoi enfin voilà
c'est ça fait jamais du bien de recevoir
du mal des gens quoi